[Music]
mary is in sunnyvale sunnyvale
california hi mary how are you
oh very good mr ramsey how are you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
well i found your book at the local
library in july of this year and you
know i read it including rachel's book
and all that but now i'm having
like
paralysis by analysis so i don't have
any consumer loan i don't have car loans
but
i have a mortgage loan again and that's
because
i paid
uh
cash for my house in 2011 but then in
2015 i refinanced it to buy a rental
unit
and then in
2018 and i saw another opportunity so i
used my heloc plus my savings to buy
another rental
last year i got laid off and so because
of low interest rate i refi to lower the
and combine my um
to lower my mortgage and then my
key lock so i got the 1.99
interest
but i didn't know it then i didn't know
that you know i should
just pay off the house and all that but
now that i've
i got laid off the recruiter of the
hospital called me back
and offering a sweet
deal
so i don't know
to pay off my mortgage should i just
sell some on my investment or should i
go back to work and pay it off and then
retire because i considered retiring
this year i mean last year
i haven't been working since last year
how old are you
uh 58 i just planned 58.
what are you you're a nurse
yes sir okay
is the duty hard
yeah if i go back to work i'm gonna work
my shift full time 12 hours each shift
why
uh yes why night shift also why work
night shift
i know because that's the only offer
they have but the hospital i'll
guarantee you there's other offers for
nurses in california
yeah but because uh if i work for the
same company i will retain my seniority
of over 25 years and inversion it didn't
forget you got you the night shift
yeah your seniority sucks
you know i get i will get i will have
the first choice of vacations and all
that and then the shift that i i mean
not the shift but like the days i want
to work but this is this is my dilemma
yeah i don't i don't have a dilemma
you're 58 you have the money not to not
work i'm not working the night shift
that sounds strenuous to me
so tell them if they want you you'll
take the day shift with your seniority
there's none or if i want to do that i
have to work night shift first for six
months and now you're done it's an
opening no you don't have to it's not a
law i know it's the offer to make a
counteroffer tell them they're stupid
i'm not coming to work over there unless
you work me during the day
because that's what my own well we have
the cna contract and who gives a credit
so what do i do i mean i can i qualify
for pension but i haven't collected it
because once i collect it then i can
only work one day a month
or i can start collecting so when i
you know
when my goal now is to pay off so what
do you make if you what do you make if
you go back
well they will give me a sign on bonus
of thirty thousand dollars and then i'm
gonna make 100 an hour
and what does day shift pay
well
there's no position for day shift it's
only for night
back to where we started yeah you're you
just don't listen okay i've told you six
times there's a day position over there
you just not you you just accept what
they tell you don't accept what they
tell you the rule on the ramsey show is
we break the rules
okay
so you you
listen do you understand what you're
saying they're willing to pay you a
hundred dollars an hour
and a thirty thousand dollar signing
bonus but you can't get the day shift
i'm calling
listen you do whatever you want to do
hon okay
that's the deal that's there's no
possible way i'm working night shift and
if you don't understand that you are in
a cat bird seat negotiating position
here go over there and smack them
between the eyes and get the day shift
and 100 an hour and a 40 000 signing
bonus they need nurses
you are in the driver's seat
okay
quit acting like all these dadgum rules
apply they don't apply
or go to work somewhere else and let
them pay you 30 000 bucks for a day
shift but don't you don't have to go
back to the night shift make it at 58
years old when you have the opportunity
to not work anymore i think you go back
to work but i think you go back to work
in a good reasonable situation and by
definition night shift is not that for
me if i'm 58. yeah i think she needs to
advocate for herself and she needs to do
some research look around to other
companies because i don't care about the
seniority if it means your life sucks
yeah so i mean
darwin they're putting like
all these things on the table that says
they desperately need you
and i'm trying to explain to you that
you have the power to overcome some of
what you perceive to be the rules
i don't perceive them to be the rules
and other if you don't go to work at
that hospital again doesn't matter to me
go to work at a doctor's office i don't
care but get you know if you can get 100
bucks overnight you can get 75 during
the day
and a signing bonus and you probably get
100 during the day right now the you
know we are in california here this is a
desperate situation and um
you know you are uh you are the hero
signing up here oh my gosh but no i'm
not gonna work six months overnight
because that's what the recruiter said
you're making more than the freaking
recruiter okay so keep in mind who's in
charge here you